Harold Reynolds is part of MLB network's
coverage of the World Series including
MLB tonight before and after every game
and HR was there at Fenway last night he
joins us now
good morning Harold how are you what up
DPS listen to you talking about the
artists playing their top hits right you
know the Dodgers to me are not playing
the top here so I'd be disappointed but
I don't see felons here in the lineup
you know they're not playing all the top
players so they're picking the hips they
want to play and then listen it - well I
like the segue there I like the segue
there thank you for helping me out there
but okay explain the strategy here when
you sit I said if you're gonna sit joc
pederson fine
you know I wouldn't sit Muncie and in
Bellinger I can't have two of my better
players sitting on the bench and getting
one at-bat no I totally agree I think
what's happening is the Dodgers hauls
really over thought the whole process
you know we watched them do the matchups
a Milwaukee sent them down this road but
they felt like they could match up and
let's show what we can do and for me to
go into an American League game and play
in an American League park with a
designated hitter
it just doesn't lend to all the moves
you have to make there's no double
switch is there's no pitcher coming up
third to lineup with somebody on base
about two pence yet that doesn't come
into play and yet they tried to force
that in these last two games in Boston
so as a result I thought their lineup
was totally out of kilter they took away
the bulk of their of their power like
you talked about with Muncie and
Ballinger and I thought it just it's
less than the team that we've seen most
of your play all right now the series
shifts to Los Angeles you have the
National League rules here how does that
change we're gonna see a lot of we're
going to see a few left-handed bats in
the lineup I'm guessing tomorrow night
in Los Angeles yeah we'll see Jack
Peterson will see Palantir will see
Muncie and there'll be a better team for
it and but I think what happens in a
nationally game and particularly from a
player standpoint you know having played
on the bench at
end of my career now one of the things
you have to do is start preparing your
thinking with the manager okay what am I
gonna
maybe pinch-run am I going to pinch-hit
am I going to go in and play defense you
know so the nationally game basically
scripts it out for it it's easier to
script and that's what the dodger front
office likes to do it script out a game
well national league you can say our
pitcher is going to be up third in the
third inning maybe we'll make a switch
and we'll go ahead and use Kemp to hit
then okay that works that doesn't work
in the American League game so I think
you know we'll double switch we'll make
we'll have we'll take Taylor out we'll
put Bellinger and Center and we'll do
that in the fifth inning you know if
things work out properly it's a lot
easier to try to determine their
outcomes and so we'll see a lot of that
from the Dodgers I think they're more
conducive to that and as a player I can
start to anticipate when I might be
going in or or not exactly I thought who
knows the other day they come back with
you know we're talking in one of the
minions after the game and we're asking
him about you know what did you do to
get ready for their bat when he hit the
three run homer he said well I knew I
wasn't starting Alex had told me the day
before the situation comes up be ready
so he's ready for the situation to face
would said I went down into the tunnel I
watched video of him I knew he was gonna
throw a breaking ball every time he had
runners in scoring position that's what
did so I look for it he had a three-run
homer that's the difference in the two
teams right now preparation
he's a Harold Reynolds Major League
Baseball Network analyst former Gold
Glove winner three-time Gold Glove
winner yes yes I know I know but you
know what's weird though you know you
loaned us your Gold Glove and it was
great to have and what people have to
understand is it's actually just a
baseball mitt that is spray-painted gold
like it's yeah I mean it's cool but it's
it's kind of a cheap you know award I
mean it's a great honor Harold don't get
me wrong I think the actual that's a
trophy they they give you is just a
glove and then they get you know
rust-oleum and then they spray pain what
last night was awarded to Johnny Molina
right so down
Bruno Clement Award looks like the
Heisman Trophy well I want it back in 91
that gave me a ball it was basically the
silver bronze like the gold the Red Sox
with two two outs in the you know this
ability they're hitting over 400 with
two outs and I guess I look at what Cora
has done for this team and what I love
and that is put the bat on the ball
don't try it you don't have to hit
homeruns they're not relying on homeruns
here and there put the ball and play and
I I don't know if more teams are gonna
look at this and go oh geez that's it
does make more sense than striking out
that you put the ball in play and then
things happen what do you make of this
Stratton it's not strategy I guess but
it's just the ability to you know put
the ball and play with with two outs in
runners in scoring position well I think
it's a philosophy that you know it's
it's blending the new analytics and also
the old school together and I think
we've gone through numbers and data are
always constantly changing right it
changes our our thought process of how
we think about things so Alex comes from
the Houston Astros who were way out
there with all their analytics yeah I
think they were the first one to sit
there and say take a pitch get deep in
the count they led the league of
strikeouts
then they made the adjustment we're
gonna put the ball in play and they win
a World Series and I think alex has
brought that here he had a quote last
night Dan that he said in the press
conference to 10 and 30 home runs and 70
RBIs you can't play for the Red Sox
doesn't get it 195 strikeouts you can't
play here well it's been accepted Oh
Harold that's the problem is baseball
has accepted this as the new normal
well I hate it I hate it I know most
people do the balls got to be in play
and if you put the ball in play good
things are going to happen a strikeouts
not just another out you have no
production so I think those teams start
to see it when you have the team leading
right now 200 in the World Series I'm
not going to give it to them yet
although I think they'll probably win it
and last year's winner saying strikeouts
is not the way you play you put the ball
in play maybe we're going to start to
see this turn in there and we'll see
because we got to get the game back to
put in the ball play you just do a
charge safe travels to Los Angeles we'll
check in with you a little bit later on
in the series thank you thank you my
friend
that's Harold Reynolds for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]